here's a question for you you're in the
business i'm in the financial industry
financial industry is the lowest for
having taken a hit
why is that why is unemployment the laws
and financial and insurance
well the fed has been very kind tell me
more
so the beauty of
jay powell pulling out the bazooka and
quantitative easing the likes of which
he's done and
making sure that companies because you
have to understand the math okay this is
pretty simple
non-financial businesses that just means
all businesses in america except for
banks
so non-financial debt as a percentage of
gdp
on december the 31st 2019 was 74 percent
that is a record in u.s history normally
again very simple math normally your
non-financial debt to gdp
peaks out during a recession right
because your gdp goes down your
denominator
goes down so as a percentage of gdp it
picks up
prior to going into recession at the end
of 2019
74 record high including any and all us
recessions
awful we were ready for not a black swan
not the coronavirus we were ready for a
sneeze because we had over leveraged
ourselves
so much so since
then and the fed knew it so
since then from
january the 1st until june the 30th
non-financial debt
in the united states has grown 2.5
trillion dollars why
because the fed forced open the markets
by saying
we will buy junk bond this is moral
hazard
the risk return that math is gone
you can take the risk we'll handle the
return don't worry we've got you covered
to quote j pal we'll make you whole
so what happens when a company that
should have gone bankrupt
like a casino operator or a
really indebted cruise line or a hotel
chain that was up to their eyeballs in
debt
when you say you know what instead of
restructuring
because your balance sheet is terrible
and you should go into restructuring and
your creditors should lose and your
shareholders should instead of that
let's instead give you more debt fine
what does that do for american banks
what does that do for the financial
industry
45 billion dollars in fee and trading
income
in the second quarter alone to the five
largest banks in america
a little gift from jay powell
that helps them offset the 25 billion
dollars that they had to set aside
for future loan losses good business
if you can get into it